we have a great voicemail number that
number
is 2192 david p and
i have a new uh top caller to play for
you today
this is a caller who i don't really
understand their message there's an
indescribable
je ne sais quoi to this voicemail there
seems to be xylophone music
playing in the background it's an
incredibly well produced voicemail
i don't know what to make of it but i
absolutely love it take a listen to this
thank you fs especially with all the
representatives
that are well anyway it's great to hear
your voice
and i'm so proud of the youth and all
that to have them tell but anyway
david pakman yeah you brought me to the
to the fact of recognizing good
television
and i'm proud of this presentation that
you represent
and thank heaven for your father and
mother for bringing up
substantial intelligent gentlemen on the
television i'm the rome jensen
i made a mistake before when i was
making presentations on how great you
are
but um yeah i was thinking about you
would be a
candidate for president wow do you for
it
six five zero oh whoa okay we don't want
to put out the uh we don't want to put
out their their phone number
uh of course i cannot be president under
the current law because i was
born in another country i immigrated to
the united states from argentina
um so i can never be president unless
the law is changed
but i really appreciate that the
xylophone in the background is
a beautiful beautiful touch i don't know
if that's digitally added or what's
going
on but thank you i don't know that i've
been called a gentleman in any voicemail
before usually i'm called other things
and it's not quite so good
we have a great bonus show for you today
georgia governor brian kemp
is banning mask mandates banning mass
mandates this will lead to unnecessary
deaths okay
period people will die who didn't have
to because
brian kemp governor of georgia is saying
cities cannot require masks to be worn
a california city has moved to replace
police
with unarmed civilians for certain types
of traffic stops it's a very interesting
proposal which we will discuss
and lastly we now are getting more and
more data about
the rehiring that is going on in some
sectors of the economy
and what we are seeing small businesses
do
is yes rehire staff but often at lower
pay
and often at fewer hours according to a
new
survey uh publicized by cnbc so we're
going to talk about
that on the bonus show as well remember
you can get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinpacman.com
if you would like a discount off of your
membership
give a try to the coupon code
july surprise all one word all lower
case july surprise
i think will give you a nice little
surprise when you use that coupon code
on a new membership
at joinpakman.com and remember as always
you can get the daily audio podcast for
free
on whatever your favorite podcasting app
is
if you are going back to work and
commuting and you want something to
listen to
if you're biking around a very safe uh
coronavirus activity
i'm listening to podcasts when i bike
around boston of course wearing a mask
and the full thing
consider the david pakman show audio
podcast spotify itunes etc etc
i'll see you on the bonus show